avec 100 de regagner s'est converti à la
trottinette électrique
il y a un mois pour lui c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un loisir c'est vraiment idéal
surtout en zone urbaine bonne vingtaine
de kilomètres de rayon on peut aller au
boulot on peut aller faire des courses
c'est très pratique c'est pia mon peu
l'entrée au travail la mettre dans un
casier il se réjouit de l'arrivée des
trottinettes électriques de l'entreprise
lime au cours des prochains jours
ces véhicules en libre-service vont
faire leur apparition dans ville-marie
avant d'être déployés ailleurs en ville
il sera possible de les louer au moyen
d'une application mobile
ça peut être perçu comme une société qui
amène un nouveau jouer à montréal pour
les montréalais pour divertir la galerie
mais je pense que les gens veulent des
nouveaux moyens de transport pour rouler
en trottinette électrique
il faudra avoir au moins 18 ans et
posséder un permis permettant de
conduire un cyclomoteur ce qui inclut
les automobilistes
les usagers pourront circuler sur des
pistes cyclables et sur les routes où la
vitesse permise est de 50 km à l'heure
où - le port du casque sera obligatoire
les trottinettes devront également être
stationnés dans des endroits désignés
avec cette réglementation la ville de
montréal espère éviter que les trottoirs
soit envahi par ces véhicules comme on
l'a vu ailleurs dans le monde
justement pour ça sourit qu'on n'allait
pas faire comme à paris ou ailleurs on a
décidé de mettre des règles très
strictes
ces prêts à aller le district les règles
sont ici à maurice on n'est plus
strictement pour les cyclistes le
partage de la route avec les
trottinettes suicide certaine crainte
car je pense que ça va juste ajouter un
problème c'est déjà dangereux sur les
pistes cyclables dont je n'ai pas de
problème avec ça je trouve qu'ils vont
trouver on les entend pas venez
à l'heure actuelle ceux qui ont leur
propre trottinettes électriques peuvent
circuler sur la voie publique avec un
seul véhicule qui a été approuvé la
djibi eric carbonneau l'a appris à ses
dépens il a écopé d'une contravention de
170 dollars parce qu'il a acheté un
autre modèle et j'ai croisé des dizaines
et des dizaines de policiers de puget
les trottinettes j'ai dépassé des
policiers sur la piste cyclable en vélo
personne n'a jamais rien dit on m'a
jamais arrêté ce matin la belgique
je tombe sur un policier peut-être un
peu seul et même les adeptes de la
trottinette n'échapperont pas aux
amandes ici olivier bastin réseau canada
montréal